la familia se reunió en torno a la tacha
para ayudarle a limpiar lo que queda de
su casa
hasta el triple ataque de la madrugada
del 7 de mayo ella habitaba esta
vivienda junto con sus cuatro hijos uno
de ellos con problemas de movilidad
dice que ahora no están aquí los ha
dejado en la casa de su abuela todos
están a salvo porque huyeron después del
primer impacto
la casa la hicimos con el préstamo hemos
pagado parte y todavía tenemos que pagar
el resto esta es una de las 25 viviendas
destruidas en una población a 10
kilómetros de crematorios donde
alrededor de 45 mil habitantes han
decidido permanecer en la ciudad
al comienzo de la invasión se temió que
el avance ruso llegaría de inmediato en
esta región del donbass en el este de
ucrania
pero pasaron semanas antes de que la
ofensiva se intensificará las provincias
de dones y lugares donde la guerra se
prolonga desde 2014 alimentada por moscú
y
no nos pasará lo mismo que mariupol y
estamos protegidos por el paisaje el río
hemos tenido suficiente tiempo durante
los últimos 72 días para prepararnos
esta es la vida que conduce hasta el isi
shanks en la región de lugansk
toda esta zona está militarizada y los
ataques son continuos
los rusos intentan destruir esta
refinería y en las últimas horas han
logrado controlar algunas poblaciones
cercanas
la situación en jacob lip k es diferente
a otros de la región aquí sus habitantes
mayoritariamente campesinos intentan
continuar su vida como oksana y su hija
lisa
estamos muy preocupados porque ellos
están acercando cada día más cigüeñas de
vuelta en crematorios olga busca los
objetos que se pudieron salvar de lo que
fue su casa
la explosión cayó a pocos metros de la
entrada
sentimos algo cerca me levanté y abrí
todas las ventanas ellos dijeron que es
mejor para la onda expansiva luego llegó
silencio oiga cuenta que se salvó porque
decidió entrar en ese momento al baño
protegido por una doble pared ocho años
han pasado desde que esta región quedará
sumergida en la guerra pero sus
habitantes reconocen que los ataques
actuales han puesto su vida al límite
como nunca antes